perhaps the best place to start actually
is looking back all the way well not
really very far 44 days six weeks of
what's happened in the pound versus the
dollar because never really have we had
a prime minister ship which has been so
defined by what's happened in markets
for the entirety of those indeed six
weeks and it's worth just running
through it this is the pound against the
US dollar there's been various other
charts we've been looking at recently in
particular Government Bond rates but
this also tells you quite a lot because
the higher that is the stronger the
pound is the lower it is the weaker the
pound is you can see the moment that Liz
trust came in and just look at this line
as it continues through September you
had obviously the mini budget now
notorious and look at what happened to
Sterling after that weakening weakening
weakening weakening getting down to
the lowest level that it's ever ever got
to against the US dollar only a few
weeks ago now and then gradually
recovering as the bank of England
intervened and of course later on
quasiquartang uh getting fired and you
can see the pound getting stronger there
and indeed all the way up to where we
are now with live trust resigning the
pound strengthened again not by all that
much frankly compared with the enormous
roller coaster that we've had since but
what this underlines is the extent to
which first this has been defined by
charts like this and secondly any future
leadership contest is likely to be
defined as well by what happens in
markets because we're in an
extraordinary moment now with a new
chancellor who can expect potentially
that he might be able to hold on to that
place if only because people are so
nervous about what's happening in
financial markets we've never seen a
prime minister ship quite like this one
both in terms of the policy in terms of
the length and in terms of the
concentration of what financial markets
think about the UK